if it's july i want to know how are you  doing with your new year's resolutions  how are you doing with your goals for  this year now i don't care when it is  you're listening to this if you end up  listening in january july november  december it doesn't matter but it's time  for a checkup because if it's the middle  of the year you can do this at any time  of year it's time to decide what goals  are you lagging on what goals are you  not  fulfilling at the pace of in which you  wanted to achieve what goals have you  given up on what goals have you allowed  this slip and you fall back into old  routines if you want to make this year  better than last year and incremental  growth is amazing even if it's a tiny  but if it's a millimeter it's growth  then it's time to do a few things it's  time to revisit your goals you should be  revisiting your goals on a weekly basis  no matter what in fact when you really  want to change your life you revisit  your goals on a daily basis such